[Musique]
sa trompe peut-être fumée noire flammes
ils sont huit mille cinq cents hommes et
femmes ils interviennent toutes les 25
secondes ils mettent leur vie en danger
pour nous secourir
les pompiers paris un corps d'élite pris
en exemple depuis longtemps à travers le
monde
depuis 50 ans il protège 124 communes
d'île de france dans des conditions
uniques dans les airs
[Musique]
dans l'eau
c'est pas pour ça
et même sous terre sur les quotas mais
nous allons suivre certains de ces
militaires hors du commun pendant une
semaine
au cab 1 un jeune breton qui vient
d'intégrer une caserne de la banlieue
nord pensent qu'à une chose j'espère je
ne peux pas me rater
à 10 et médecins elle va devoir
affronter ses peurs
sébastien est spécialiste des incendies
intense s'entraîne sans relâche ou
techniques les plus innovantes
on prépare la mousse colin tenus à notre
casque et on a tout de suite la vision
occulté jennifer maîtres chiens elles
fouillent les décombres avec son fidèle
compagnon falgos dire bah ya des gens en
dessous il faut faut y aller faut se
dépêcher clément est médecin militaire
il doit faire face aux drames de la vie
écoutez moi avec les pompiers vous a
fait une crise d'épilepsie ou encore
damien qui au musée d'orsay protège
l'une des plus belles collections au
monde d'art moderne là on est conscient
ce qu'on déplace vaut très cher tous
n'ont qu'une devise sauver ou périr
[Musique]
clichy sous bois au nord-est de paris
nous sommes lundi matin il est 8 heures
gabin jeunes pompiers de 22 ans débute
sa garde
[Musique]
ça représente vraiment le pompier ça
concrétise vraiment un rêve d'enfant
c'est dans ce que je voulais faire
depuis tout petit
et il y a une chose en particulier qui
l'a d'abord attiré s'il est convié
je crois que c'est comme tout le monde
le camion rouge depuis tout petit ce têt
pompiers et voir passer
faire des interventions c'est quelque
chose qui me plaisait ça m'a toujours
plu
originaire de bretagne dans sa caserne
gabin et le plus jeune arrivée il n'a
que huit mois de service et il doit
encore faire ses preuves
le jeune homme doit aussi se
familiariser avec les us et coutumes des
pompiers de paris c'est le cas chaque
lundi matin lorsque la brigade rend
hommage à ses morts à l'appel
pour moi la cérémonie des morts au feu
c'est important parce que ça permet de
nous souvenir de nos camarades qui ont
laissé la vie sapeur de 1ère classe dit
un mot
ça nous met en garde sur le métier qu'on
fait on fait pas un métier ni d'un fait
un métier qui est qui à risques et des
dangers
on part sur feu on sait pas ce qui peut
se passer
gabin le sait chaque semaine après
l'appel aux morts il est confronté à une
autre épreuve peu après la cérémonie on
passe à l'épreuve de la planche donc la
planche si c'est pas n'importe quoi
c'est
meetic la brigade
compte en dix ans le service commandants
d'unités
[Musique]
devant tout le monde un à un du plus
gradé au dernière arrivée les pompiers
doivent se redresser seul à la force des
bras sur une planche à 2 mètres 40 du
sol à la base ça permettait d'évaluer le
niveau physique du sapeur pompier un
personnel qui ne pouvaient pas à monter
la planche n'étaient pas aptes à monter
dans un an jean
gabin commence à bien connaître cette
épreuve mais il n'en garde pas moins une
certaine appréhension est là quand je
suis dans les rangs je pense qu'à une
chose et j'espère je vais pas me rater
raté la planche ces os et montrer qu'on
n'est pas au niveau et moi j'ai pas
envie de passer pour quelqu'un pour un
rigolo c'est enfin à son tour de passer
jus très concentré
dentiste de vous pris ma planche
ça permet de prouver aux autres que j'ai
ma place dans la compagnie
au sein des casernes en dehors des
interventions chaque pompier à une tâche
définie et lorsqu'on et première classe
le garde le moins élevé il faut accepter
même les plus ingrates
et le rituel comment vers l'arrivée
c'est là qu'il
est bien le trouver dans la musique
aujourd'hui il aide à la cuisine au
service du repas lors le première place
en compagnie d'un rôle d'homme à tout
faire chez les travaux d'intérêts
généraux le réfectoire la plonge la
cuisine pour section service ordinaire
du nettoyage de locaux communs c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne en quantité
ça c'est bien
heureusement pour gabin d'ici quelques
heures il va pouvoir pleinement joué son
rôle de pompier
10 km plus au nord à la caserne du blanc
mesnil
sébastien novembre service
l' alerte incendie résonne
sous pavillon 4 ans peut-être fumée
noire flammes
en moins de deux minutes le fourgon et
ses 3000 litres d'eau s'élance toutes
sirènes hurlantes à l'arrière les hommes
en files casse tenue de feu et appareils
respiratoires
très vite les pompiers réalise la
gravité de la situation
dans la rue à l'adresse indiquée on
commence déjà à voir au loin le panache
de fumée donc là on doute que ça brûle
bien
immédiatement les pompiers déploient les
400 mètres de tuyaux
arrivent en camion était totalement
embrasée ça sortait par la fenêtre donc
le premier but de notre chef de garde
c'est préserver les pavillons alentours
et de que le feu ne prennent pas plus
d'emplois que le pavillon lui-même
c'est une simple bougie allumée trop
près d'un rideau qui est à l'origine du
sinistre les occupants du petit deux
pièces ont pu sortir il n'y a aucune
victime mais les pompiers tentent de
sauver ce qu'il reste de l'habitation
chaque tuyau expulse eu 500 litres d'eau
à la minute
à ceux-là mois
différentes techniques pour être un à
feu ce soit des impulsions ou alors une
méthode de crayonnage on va bien faire
des
des grands s à l'intérieur du feu pour
pouvoir balayer un maximum les fumées
les flammes et l'éteindre en rapidement
de l'extérieur l'incendié semblait
maîtrisé
les pompiers peuvent entrer
mais en pénétrant dans une maison en feu
ils ne savent jamais ce à quoi ils vont
être confrontés
[Musique]
les hommes et à nier les dernières
flammes
l'incendié a tout détruit la chaleur est
montée à 800 degrés quatre fois la
température d'un cours de cuisine
les objets du quotidien ont brûlé ou
fondu
[Musique]
les souvenirs sont partis en fumée
une fois l'incendié éteint le risque
mais pas totalement écarter les pompiers
sortent un autre outil un moment mais la
ventilation opérationnelle sa sert a
poussé les fumées on meurt dans un
incendie du fait des fumées et non de
l'élan des flammes
parfois on peut voir les fumées qui sont
au dessus de nous et qui ont qui sont
gorgés de gaz et qui peuvent s'enflammer
rapidement
à l'intérieur c'est le chaos il ne
subsiste presque rien ce que le feu n'a
pas détruit ce sont les tonnes d'eau
déversées qui s'en sont chargés
avant de partir les pompiers vont
vérifier que tout danger est écarté et
pour cela ils font appel à la
technologie la lettre de notre caméra
thermique on regarde si encore des
points chauds si encore des points
chauds nous bouger de sortir deux cas
c'est de continuer à arroser pour
s'assurer que le feu soit bien l'état
qui ne couvre pas
fin d'intervention pour sébastien et ses
coéquipiers
dans quelques jours ils s'entraîneront à
éteindre un feu avec une technique très
original
construite sur la colline de montmartre
point culminant de paris la basilique du
sacré-coeur héberge aujourd'hui encore
la communauté des bénédictines
derrière le dôme un lieu interdit au
public le campanile
seuls quelques privilégiés ont accès à
cet escalier les hommes du grimp le
groupe de reconnaissance et
d'intervention en milieu périlleux en
font partie
cette unité de 17 pompiers intervient
quand les auteurs sont extrêmes et
l'accès impossible
le campanile de montmartre 500 marche 83
m de haut aucun matériel au niveau du
soleil et tout en haut
l'une des plus belles vues au monde
[Musique]
des privilégiés de force dans des
endroits des monuments pareil
fm on parle à ce sacré coeur
le grand palais et en plus de ça on fait
enfin métier qu'on aime la technique est
un pas en arrive à se faire plaisir ça
c'est quand même top on vit notre est le
boss on l'a vu aujourd'hui de l'entrevue
[Musique]
les freins qui dépasse le noeud julien
depuis 16 ans la brigade dirige
l'exercice c'est la première fois qu'on
manoeuvre aujourd'hui sur le sacré coeur
le but c'est de s'entraîner sur le
campanile qui se trouve derrière et qui
est vraiment fermé au public 1 cette
manoeuvre est exceptionnel parce que
déjà on manoeuvre sur un monument qui
est classé les deux autres sur corps
donc avec les boutefeux 30 net l'idée
c'est d'aller chercher là haut d'accord
donc on doit venir mettre la politique
ce vraiment sur le groupe signé si donc
on va monter par l'escalier tu as réussi
à la passer
l'exercice consiste à descendre une
victime du haut du campanile grâce à un
système de tyroliennes
alors là j'ai deux sauveteurs qui sont
en partie haute sur corde dans le vide
et sont en train de mettre dispositif
qui va nous permettre d'attaquer tout la
tyrolienne en partie haute et la
tyrolienne donc ensuite va filer à
travers la grande arche juste de soul et
c'est là le point clé de la réussite de
cette manip 1 c'est à eux de me mettre
du 10 yeuse man se cette politique voilà
ça sera le début de la tyrolienne
[Musique]
déverrouillez aussi avec l'acier qui ce
matin m
on commence à glisser la fouly principal
de la valeur sur le point haut
pour voir dans un premier temps de
travail ça correspond s'il faut modifier
le dispositif ou pas quoi tout est prêt
un jeune pompier est harnaché à la
civière et on a beau avoir l'habitude du
vide il faut d'avoir confiance en ses
camarades
et non les fourrages eux après c'est pas
de la tour du bolide
j'ai dû rattraper retour sur un contrat
pro mais le plus d'envié nous l'objectif
c'est quand même de mettre quelqu'un
dans le vide à des auteurs qui sont sont
pas qu'ils sont pas anodines donc il ya
du danger il faut toujours être présent
faut toujours être concentré ok steve
donc je mets un oeil sur corde à
l'extérieur
voilà
vivant au la bible il faut que tu
t'écartes tu laisses passer
super le tout ça y est après une heure
d'effort la manoeuvre est lancé
[Musique]
l'opposition est
suspendu dans le vide au bout d'une
corde et d'une poulie à plus de 80
mètres du sol la hauteur d'un immeuble
de 25 étages
le brancard descend calmement mais
tangue au gré du vent
[Musique]
trois minutes plus tard le brancard
s'approche du sol les hommes du grimp
peuvent souffler le jeune pompier lui
n'oubliera jamais cette descente c'est
la première fois que je vois paris ne
s'est hélas est vrai que ça fait bizarre
de se retrouver rohit pires récentes
j'ai pas une mission du sensible c'est
quand même assez haut mais ça s'est bien
passé une fin d'exercice le sacré-coeur
retrouve sa quiétude
le lendemain au nord de paris à
saint-denis
il est 7 heures du matin entre chien et
loup
jennifer est pompier maîtres chiens
quand le jour sera levé elle va
organiser un entraînement pour ces
animaux d'élite
[Musique]
fait exprès de mettre les chiens par
groupes de deux ou trois pour minimum
pour favoriser la sociabilisation comme
ça quand on les sort et vous fait des
interventions on a on peut écarter la
plupart du temps le souci des chiens qui
vont peut-être d'aller se battre avec
d'autres chiens qui se promène en forêt
ou n'importe où
ça c'est le mien alors c'est fois le
coach est opérationnel il a il va avoir
7 ans cette année les vingt chiens
pompiers de la brigade sont entraînés à
rechercher des personnes disparues ou
ensevelies
et alors que le jour se lève les chiens
pompiers vont s'entraîner dans un lieu
bien particulier
juste derrière nos jeunes il en a
construit un petit terrain de décombres
avec des caches un peu spécifique dont
complètement différentes les unes des
autres on essaye de créer à nos chiens
tous les différents environnements qui
sera possible pour eux de retrouver sur
ce recherche donc une voiture un
appartement des bureaux tout ce qu'ils
ont fait ce qu'on va pouvoir lui montrer
et lui apprendre là il sera pas étonné
quand il le verra sur intervention il
aura déjà vu il sera qu'une voiture peut
être sous la terre qu'il ya des gens qui
peuvent être dans des gros trous et
qu'il ya des gens qui peuvent être en
hauteur lui fait part vraiment tout ce
qui pourra rencontrer
pour cet exercice l'un des maîtres
chiens des sens dans ces décombres
il choisit une cachette
puis il s'y terre
falco le chien de jennifer doit le
retrouver
chiens courent pas aux as il va courir
sur le secteur qu'on lui donne et il va
se diriger en fonction du des effluents
de l'odeur humaine qui pend à savoir que
nos chiens ne cherche pas une odeur
spécifique
il cherche toute odeur humaine
après seulement quelques secondes falco
semble être sur la bonne piste
[Musique]
là on voit que le chien des sens parce
que l'odeur vient de vient de la
profondeur donc il va descendre et une
fois arrivé en bas il ya différents de
route il peut y avoir différents
endroits au nez il va commencer à se
diriger plus à droite plus à gauche
essayer de remonter au plus près de la
victime le chien averti alors jennifer
falco a réussi sa mission
jennifer sait que son vieux compagnon
est toujours apte au service
en moyenne les chiens de la brigade
interviennent 50 fois par an et ce sont
parfois des cas extrêmes il ya quelques
années
jennifer et talgo ont dû intervenir lors
d'un accident très impressionnant nous
sommes le 31 août 2014 à rosny sous bois
cet immeuble vient d'être éventré par
une explosion due au gaz
jennifer est l'un des premiers maîtres
chiens engagés sur l'effondrement
quand j'arrive sur les lieux on voit qui
a vraiment énormément de décompte
partout que ça va être une recherche
quand même compliqué parce qu'il ya déjà
beaucoup de sauveteurs sur les lieux
donc beaucoup d'odeurs déjà présente et
qui vont rester sur les cailloux pas
beaucoup donc d'intérêt de nos chiens à
différents endroits et puis il va le
stress de l'intervention dans le stress
de se dire bah ya des gens au dessous il
faut faut y aller faut se dépêcher parce
que elles sont classiques ou quatre
étages se sont effondrés il ne reste
qu'un tas de gravats voilà là à la fin
de cette intervention je vais savoir si
vraiment tout le travail que j'ai
effectué jusqu'à maintenant avec mon
chien est ce que c'est ça porte vraiment
complètement cefrio pas ce jour là deux
chiens sont engagés falco son fidèle
compagnon mais aussi hugo
ensemble ils cherchent sous les gravats
les odeurs humaine
l'explosion est survenue un dimanche
matin l'immeuble était plein les
sauveteurs s'attendent à trouver de
nombreuses victimes
très vite une première personne vivante
et découvertes
avec précaution l'homme commence à être
dégagé
[Musique]
on espère toujours nous quand on monte
sur un décompte trouver des personnes
vivantes et pouvoir les sortir
dans les premières heures deux personnes
sortent vivante de l'amas de gravats les
recherches durent près de 48 heures
falco a réussi à me montrer et à me
marquer six ou sept victimes ensevelies
sous les décombres donc un très très bon
travail de lapin mon chien très contente
de ce qu'il a fait mais malgré leurs
efforts les sauveteurs ne sortiront plus
aucun survivant cet effondrement est le
plus meurtrier de ces dix dernières
années
dans quelques jours c'est un exercice
qui attend jennifer et chalco ils
devront rechercher un homme perdu en
forêt
direction asnières sur seine au nord
ouest de paris
cette fois le grimp est appelée sur un
chantier
quand on se présente sur l'intervention
je constate effectivement qu'il ya un
homme qui tout en haut d'une grue à peu
près à une 30 40 mètres environ l'homme
est en danger pourtant il ne s'agit ni
d'un accident ni d'une tentative de
suicide on comprend qu'il veut pas se
jeter et tout ce qu'il veut s'il était
tout simplement l'ouvrier n'a pas reçu
son salaire et tentent de faire pression
sur son patron l'homme au casque blanc
les pompiers ne sont plus qu'à quelques
mètres de l'ouvrier mais il leur
interdit de monter
pourquoi
ce genre d'intervention c'est toujours
très délicat c'est très intense parce
que déjà ça a tendance à durer très
longtemps le but du jeu c'est que la
personne reviennent vers nous et
descendre avec nous par l'ascenseur ou
les escaliers les hommes du grimp savent
que l'homme ne sautera pas ce qu'ils
redoutent c'est une chute des gens qui
veulent vraiment suicidé ils sont au
bout et puis monsieur ries
en plus il est dit clairement il veut
pas sauter juste et deux pays
non il faut à temps
ça reste quand même dangereux parce que
on est sur une grue on y sur un chantier
il ya de la hauteur et puis bon c'est
leur soit aussi que le monsieur il est
monté tout en haut de la grue vraiment
il est à l'extrémité de la grue donc
même s'il veut pas se jeter il ya
toujours un risque de chute que ce
monsieur by rip son quine nice puis by
temps seule solution la négociation en
bas le frère de l'ouvrier tente de le
raisonner par téléphone et le dialogue
entre les deux hommes semble porter ses
fruits
d'après une info
l'ouvrier accepte finalement de quitter
la grue mais les pompiers restent
prudents la descente est un moment
délicat
le risque qu'on attrape quelqu'un qui
veut jeter ou portent ces deux aussi de
toi de ton bébé - où est la sécurité
mais surtout de lui tombe à cause de
taux sur
l'ouvrier a obtenu gain de cause il sera
bien payé les hommes du grimp peuvent
retirer leur baudriller
à quelques kilomètres de là autre
pompier autre ambiance à
clichy-sous-bois gabin le jeune pompier
de 22 ans dernière arrivée à la caserne
c'est ma deuxième maison ici je pense
autant de temps ici que que je suis mort
comme chaque matin en bon militaire le
jeune homme doit faire son lit au carré
correctement
sa chambre il la partage avec six de ses
collègues tous ne sont pas présents en
même temps ça dépend des gardes de
chacun des gars de 24 ou 48 heures sur
une année ils passent la moitié de leur
nuit dans leur lit à la caserne à charge
c'est important c'est l'abus l'intérieur
dans une grosse bulle la grosse bulle
c'est la caserne et manou la pit bulls
notre chambre ça me permet de
décompresser de rigoler nous partager
des moments avec nos collègues des
collègues qui peuvent aussi s'improviser
coiffeur il faut dire que la coupe de
gabin n'est pas très compliqué terme
on doit avoir les cheveux courts éviter
d'avoir des démarcations qu'un léger
dégradé et avec des chaussures de sucre
sont pas trop trop bien
[Musique]
étant donné qu'on est militaire ne se
doit d'avoir les chevaux
[Musique]
mais tu te pompier m'a toujours attiré
je sais pas pourquoi c'est le danger
c'est l'adrénaline
c'est quelque chose que je recherche et
enfin en étant acteur en étant à clichy
sous bois j'en retrouve quand même ses
autres pas mal de ce que je recherchais
et parmi ces choses l'adrénaline du
départ
dans les couloirs la larme raisonne sur
l'ensemble des casernes les pompiers de
paris interviennent sur des urgences
1400 fois par tour
buts
[Musique]
avec ses coéquipiers et son chef gabin
se déplace chez une dame de 85 ans
arrivés sur les lieux ils ont un vécu le
matériel de base de quoi assurer les
premiers gestes de faire face à toutes
les situations
et chacun a un rôle bien défini moi mon
rôle c'est de faire un bilan prendre des
constantes on prend un point une
ventilation une tension une saturation
seulement ce n'est pas toujours facile
de savoir comment se comporter face aux
victimes
ça vous fait mal vous êtes tombé je
devais reprendre une tension
surtout lorsqu'on a seulement 22 ans et
qu'on est confronté à la détresse gabin
tente de trouver les mots justes mais
non ça
ne dit pas ça madame ça va
nous aider j'en suis
mais bon c'est pour ça que c'est quoi
comment
et pourquoi une belle maison vous êtes
bien là
j'ai écouté la dame
même à parler je sais pas s'il a fait du
bien de me parler ou pas mais enfin nous
soit on a souvent ce rôle-là de
psychologues entre guillemets moi je
trouve qu une détresse psychologique
c'est plus dur appréhendé parce que
justement on n'a pas de fiche technique
pour les essences psychologique n'a pas
de fiche technique on a pas de conduite
à tenir particulière alors que pour un
arrêt on sait que on sait ce qu'on a à
faire
pour trouver la cause du malaise de la
vieille dame les pompiers décident de
l'emmener aux urgences et là encore
gamin va devoir se montrer rassurant
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas bien là
pourquoi donner envie de vomir
j'avais fait un petit malaise comme hier
on vous envoie l'hôpital
on arrive bientôt en plus je pense pas
que ce que je lui ai dit un poids j'ai
plus l'impression de m'adresser un mur
qu'on avait voulu dire que ça allait
bien se passer qu'on allait l'aider qu'à
l'hôpital les allées bien s'occuper
d'elle gagnerait peut-être tout le temps
la même chose
que voulez pas saunier qu'elle voulait
juste mourir il fallait qu'on la laisse
tranquille
je
tout le bien m'occuper de la personne
n'est obligé de faire la part des choses
je fais preuve de compassion mais je
vais pas me rendent malade pour pour sa
voix après j'essaye de comprendre
personnes au maximum mais c'est pas
facile
malgré son jeune âge gabin apprend déjà
à se protéger et sa garde est loin
d'être terminée
l'âme de paris c'est son fleuve la scène
classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
et elle aussi elle a 16 ans gardien
hugo 24 ans est l'un d'entre eux avec
ses coéquipiers il vient d'être appelé
au secours de l'un des usagers du fleuve
parisien
ils font partie des soixante deux
plongeurs et sauveteurs aquatiques de la
brigade
propulsé par un hydro jet leurs
embarcations filent à 35 noeuds
65 kilomètres/heure soir sarah touareg
on intervient sur vraiment tout type de
population peut être n'importe qui
touristes aux fêtards qui
veulent se refroidir un petit peu se
jette à l'autre à bord de leur bateau
ils ont le même équipement qu'une
ambulance de premiers secours on part
pour une faire turrian concurrence et
une femme
enfin enceinte qu'à une perte sans sur
un bateau mouche une touriste
autrichienne a demandé de l'aide
on lui pose des questions élémentaires
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce
qu'elle a vu qu'est ce qu'elle a
ressenti ou est-ce que la malle hugo
pratique un premier examen rapide il
relève les données de base température
taux d'oxygène dans le sang et tensions
la jeune femme nécessite d'être évacués
l'équipe attend une ambulance
les pompiers du secteur prennent en
charge la jeune touriste
non monaco
pour maternité
comme pour la plupart des interventions
hugo et ses collègues ne connaîtront pas
la fin de l'histoire
10 millions de touristes étrangers
visitent paris chaque année une très
grande partie d'entre eux passent sur
les quais de seine ils dépendent alors
des plongeurs de la brigade dont la
caserne est cette barge amarrée à côté
du pont neuf
alors qu'une victime ne s'est pas ne se
contrôle pas en l'air et peu en contact
de l'eau se faire un trauma du rachis
c'est comme si et percuté un mur
hector stage
je parle
le port
la tête doit être maintenu la nuque et
souvent fragilisées par le choc
ok ne bougeait pas la tête monsieur
leubou j'ai pas la tête attention pour
lever
jusqu'à un exercice qu'on fait
pratiquement au quotidien pour avoir des
gestes réflexes il sert à a conditionné
une victime donc soit en arrêt cardio
respiratoire ou en état d'hypothermie
avancée car au jour d'aujourd'hui avec
les températures qui fait notamment en
hiver on a des températures à
3,4 degrés température de l'eau je parle
bien sûr donc une victime clan très
rapidement en état d'hypothermie
températures très basses du corps
en dessous de 28 degrés hypothermie et
sévère elle peut être fatale ne fait pas
que cueillir la victime dans l'eau et on
ne fait pas que la sortir on effectue
des gestes de secourisme dessus donc qui
discourent isdi administration d'oxygène
massage cardiaque
je touche au niveau décembre je le sens
où j'ai vos pieds s'il vous plaît ok
très bien
aujourd'hui tout s'est bien passé
j'ai toujours aimé l'eau et pouvoir se
baigner
dans paris au milieu de tous ces ponts
tous ces monuments c'est une chance
exceptionnelle je me sens complètement
privilégié en faisant ce métier
la vedette fil sur l'eau
la zone d'intervention de la brigade est
vaste de villeneuve le roi dans l'est à
chatou dans l'ouest la scène serpente
sur 145 km
mais les pompiers n'ont pas que la scène
comme terrain de jeu dans quelques jours
ils feront une plongée mythique réservé
aux seuls initiés
en attendant une journée s'achève sur la
caserne du pont-neuf
jeudi matin banlieue sud de paris
dans la remise de la caserne du plessis
clamart clément médecin à la brigade
commença gardes de 24 heures et à chaque
fois c'est le même rituel
l'infirmier aidé par le médecin vérifie
combien dans pool on a de chaque
médicament est ce qu'elles sont périmés
est-ce que tout le matériel électrique
marche
il ya plus de volumes en hausse et
une ambulance de réanimation c'est
vraiment une unité hospitalière capable
de prendre en charge des détresses
vitales extrêmement variées qui vont de
la femme qui accouche avec son nouveau
né qui pourraient aller mal jusqu'au
polytraumatisé d'accidents de la route à
l'infarctus à l'arrêt cardiaque
justement à peine le temps de finir la
vérification l'équipe est appelée sur
une première urgence une urgence vitale
on se déplace très rapidement au
domicile d'une dame qui au petit matin
et retrouvée d'un arrêt cardiaque
direction châtenay malabry ya quatre
kilomètres de là au volant l'ambulancier
c'est qu'il n'a pas de temps à perdre en
moins de cinq minutes clément ils sont
infirmiers arrivent sur place
la situation est critique
les pompiers prennent le relais du fils
de la victime
quand on arrive son fils est en train de
réaliser un massage cardiaque c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
pour nous on sait qu'un patient qui
n'est pas masser chaque minute qui passe
il perd 10% de changer sur 80 il en
arrêt cardiaque
trois deux un pot de massage
un massage ça une certaine forme de
violence on impose à un corps un
enfoncement du thorax cette violence
elle est nécessaire il faut faire il
faut enfoncer la poitrine 100 fois par
minute et fall enfoncé de cinq à six
centimètres
c'est très spectaculaire mais c'est très
efficace
et pour garder ce rythme les pompiers
utilisent un grand et on
écoute bien le métronome quand on fait
dans l'animation il ya beaucoup
d'informations données par nos machines
elle a une mère en plus volontiers la
métronome c'est le bipe qu'on entend en
permanence pendant la réanimation ce
métronome est une exigence pour le
pompier qui masse de se tenir à 100 par
minute le stress la fatigue fait qu'on
peut accélérer ou qu'on peut ralentir
on leur demande de masser pendant deux
minutes et au bout de minutes il ya un
autre pompier qui prend le relais c'est
vraiment une lutte acharnée pour la
survie des patients
cela fait déjà dix minutes maintenant
que les pompiers tentent de réanimer la
vieille dame en vain malgré l'urgence
clément prend le temps de tenir informé
la famille
le choeur est arrêté on fait tout ce
qu'on peut pour le relancer je vous
cache pas que la situation est très
grave et qui a très peu d'espoir je
viens vous revoir dès que je peux vous
pouvez venir voir si vous voulez vous
n'êtes pas obligé c'est comme vous le
sentez d'accord
trois
reprises après 20 minutes clément est
très pessimiste
adri je vous cache pas que là vos
efforts de bonne qualité donc on ne
s'approche pas d'une victoire il ya
plusieurs signes qui montrent que c'est
quand même panier
malgré le massage cardiaque la
ventilation et les injections clément
comprend qu'il n'ya plus rien à faire
[Musique]
la lutte aura duré une demi heure le
plus dur attend clément il doit prévenir
la famille je vais leur proposer mais je
pense que
la partie sans souffrir
fait tout ce qu'il a dit
quand la vie s'en va au bout d'un moment
le large hier
une certaine brutalité qu'on ne peut pas
forcément attendrir
n'enlève tous nos appareils électriques
qui deviendra congrue brutalement et on
remet le corps du coup c'est plus une
patiente qu'on veut ranimer c'est un
corps défunt on va être installé
proprement dans un lit
l'intervention est terminée
les pompiers retourne à la caserne
quand tout à coup
on est de retour d'intervention et
soudain on arrive sur un véhicule en feu
sur le périphérique quand on arrive des
gendarmes sont en train de canaliser la
circulation ils sont sur la voie opposée
se sont arrêtés et il limite la
circulation à une voie tout en attaquant
un incendie avec des extincteurs un peu
petit
[Musique]
clément n'est pas censé lutter contre le
feu ils demandent du renfort
peu de véhicules camionnette j'engage
les personnels de l'air avec détecteur
mauvaise surprise en ouvrant les portes
du camion il est chargé de vêtements
le feu risque de se propager rapidement
il faut réagir
décide de rentrer dans ce qu'elles m'ont
tant qu'il en est encore temps pour
faire une chaîne avec les gendarmes et
vidé le plus possible les ballots de
linge et les évacuer au moins et limiter
les incendies au compartiment avant du
moteur à ce moment là quand on rentre
dans le camion il est vrai qu'on
intervient vraiment rapidement ne prend
pas le temps de mettre nos effets de
protection et probablement qu'on aurait
dû mettre ses tenues quand l' incendie
prend trop d'importance on se met en
sécurité donc il peut camions en
quelques minutes à peine les renforts
demandés par clément arrive escorté par
la police le camion pompe remonte le
périphérique à contre sens
la circulation est coupée les soldats du
feu interviennent
à
l'écart vincent l'ambulancier de clément
lui détail l'opération
l'ambulancier et l'infirmier sont très
souvent d'anciens pompiers qui
connaissent le feu vincent tu prends le
temps de m'expliquer comment elle était
un incendie de véhicule j'en ai aucune
expérience aucune idée
de faire baisser rapidement afin de
déployer du jeu par des impulsions sa
couche les flammes ont fait baisser
rapidement la température et une fois
que tu as fini avec des gros débiles tu
baisses ton est vite ajoute que jean
marc rozé doucement sur les quelques
places qui restent et sont des points et
des points parce qu les termes vous
installez pneus moteurs
sacrément seront alors à savoir ça
craint suspensif
[Musique]
je serai jamais un pompier un soldat du
feu c'est un nom de travail en revanche
plus je connais le travail des pompiers
du feu plus je peux les soutenir avec
efficacité parler le même langage qu'eux
et être à leur profit après une demi
heure d'intervention l'incendié était
éteint et le périphérique est rouvert à
la circulation
une intervention qui comme toutes les
autres a transité par un lieu unique
quelque part dans paris une caserne
abrite l'état-major des pompiers pour y
accéder il faut montrer patte blanche
cet endroit est strictement interdite au
public
il s'agit du centre opérationnel là où
arrivent les appels du 18
300 pompiers se relaient 24 heures sur
24 pour répondre aux six mille appels
quotidiens un appel toutes les 25
secondes
ici on ce monsieur aux tno
il est pas lutté deux seuls 1400 appels
par jour donne lieu à une intervention
en permanence trois médecin un infirmier
et huit opérateurs gèrent ces urgences
quotidiennes plus ou moins graves
aujourd'hui anne lise médecin urgentiste
depuis dix ans a la lourde tâche de
gérer les secours médicaux ont du mal à
parler ça pendant des gars de 8 ou 12
heures pendu au téléphone elle oriente
les premiers secours vous avez
l'impression que l'air est bloquée
monsieur pourquoi il appelle aujourd'hui
c'est la manne de glisse
et réalise des diagnostics à distance
[Musique]
l'intensité croissante
régulation médicale c'est la prise de
décisions d'envoi de moyens mais quels
moyens est ce que ce patient nécessite
une ambulance de réanimation parce qu'il
est en train de faire un infarctus par
exemple ou est-ce que ce patient en fait
une équipe de pompiers suffira on envoie
la longueur the réanimation pour
permettre à la personne de survivre donc
on est en général dans des situations
critiques
la difficulté est de comprendre le cas
sans voir le patient c'est une vraie
enquête cannes nice mène à distance n'y
a pas eu peur en fait mais tu voyais à
la fatigue arrive pas il semble en effet
que j'avais trouvé qu'ils avaient pensé
à un enseignement de quelque part moi ce
qui me gêne c'est que tu as vu il a une
tension milite à 9,6 les planeurs les
u19 et régulier on va déjà faire un de
ses jets par ce qui se passe ainsi je
vous appelle maintenant moi non parce
que je cherchais plus ils savaient pas
signé ou c'est qu'on est au téléphone en
un peu un détective quoi on va à la
pêche aux renseignements il n'y a pas de
paralysie faciale
il n'y a pas de déficit dont super
membres inférieurs il s'est réveillé
comme ça quand ils tirent la langue la
langue elle sort droite parfois on
demande un électrocardiogramme on
demande aux pompiers qui sont sur place
de voir s'il n'y a pas des courriers ou
des prises de sang qui ont été faites
dans un laboratoire les jours précédents
par des petits renseignements on a on
essaye de faire un lien pour prendre la
meilleure décision
l'électrocardiogramme ya pas de
nos manies aiguë d'accord elle va voir
son gynécologue tranquillement et on
peut la laisser sur place ok
le secours à victimes ne cesse de
prendre de l'ampleur ils représentent
désormais 80% de l'activité des pompiers
de paris
anne-lise elle va bientôt quitter son
bureau pour une intervention sur le
terrain
à quelques kilomètres de la banlieue est
de paris c'est une intervention un peu
spécial qui s'annonce un homme dans un
état grave est coincé chez lui les
pompiers du grimp doivent trouver une
solution pour l'évacuer julien brive ses
hommes alors messieurs on a rendez nous
avons un homme en urgence absolue je me
suis à duffort corpulence d'accord il
fait à peu près 120 130 kg il est
conscient mais seulement faut qu'il soit
transporté dans les plus brefs délais à
l'hôpital messieurs il est 2h30 4 il
nous reste à peu près 45 minutes à peine
quand on parle d'urgence vitale de
détresse 45 minutes ça peut paraître
très très long mais c'est pas anodin de
passer quelqu'un par la fenêtre le
risque est toujours le même c'est de
faire tomber cette personne par la
fenêtre donc effectivement on ne peut
pas attendre une corde en cinq minutes
et mettre tout le monde comme ça j'étais
comme une furie une furie comme un
accrobranche non ça marche pas comme ça
pour sortir l'homme les pompiers vont
mettre en place un système de
tyroliennes le même qu'au sacré coeur
le décor de rouge par par douze cordes
ou blanches traction on ya plusieurs
types de corps d'un père ce dispositif
il ya des cordes qui supportent tout
l'ensemble des cordes qui tirent et des
cordes qui retiennent tout s'accumule et
ça fait que l'on peut monter trans
latter décembre enfin c'est comme un
mini ascenseur mais sur kant en
attendant que l'installation soit prête
le patient a été stabilisé dans sa
chambre par une équipe médicale
vient d'outré tombe relevé levet
l'homme est placé sur une civière dans
quelques instants il sera suspendu dans
le vide
ça a l'air compliqué comme ça ne c'est
juste
si le brancard légèrement inclinée on
peut avec le poivre
c'est vrai monsieur vous allez bien
cordes poulies et mousquetons sans fixer
l'opération va pouvoir débuter
à qui on monte sur le trône en avant
pour le brancardage en laisse pas
basculer
voilà tous les maux traction à venir le
moment critique dans ce type
d'intervention c'est toujours la sortie
civière c'est quand on met la personne
par la fenêtre
attention on attend deux petites
secondes on fait une petite modif ici à
les tractions maintenant c'est bon
tu peux commencer à laisser partir
l'homme est désormais seul dans les airs
vous le tenez au maximum le plus loin
possible les gars ont bien droit tout
est mis en place pour éviter que le
brancard ne bascule en fait est que la
victime de tombes
[Musique]
je vois
finalement la civière ne fait
qu'effleurer le petit olivier
[Musique]
c'est bien là ouais là c'est bien là le
fond
patin la descente de temps
[Musique]
après à peine trois minutes de descente
l'homme retrouve la terre ferme
on va vous mettre au chaud
l'homme sera pris en charge dans
l'hôpital le plus proche dans les
minutes qui viennent
sur l'ensemble des évacuations de
patients un peu moins d'une centaine
nécessitent chaque année l'intervention
du grimp
julien est satisfait de cette opération
aérienne
dans quelques jours il va se retrouver
30 mètres sous terre
dauger une banque hu qui étaient
installés par garnier en à l'époque de
la construction donc en 1860 pour
asseoir le bâtiment pour donner un poids
pour donner un poisson lune assise à son
bâtiment pour qu'il est construit sur un
marais
c'est dans ces eaux que l'école de
plongée de la brigade s'entraîne dur et
de travail on part sur trente minutes
la profondeur et si on sait qu'à pas de
souci en beta de m faites attention ne
pas me remuer trop les particules pour
les pandores suivant
les pompiers sont les seuls une fois par
mois à pouvoir profiter de ces eaux
limpides
aucune rivière n'est à l'origine de ce
miracle
le lac est alimentée par le réseau d'eau
de la ville de paris
en plein centre de paris
des plus belles scènes de paris donc
c'est vraiment vraiment un privilège de
plonger
quelques frissons
à la recherche du fantôme de l'opéra qui
se cacherait derrière les piliers de
cette réserve d'eau une réserve qui un
temps servi à sauvegarder le bâtiment de
l'incendié
[Musique]
un fils lumineux permet aux hommes de se
guider un lien indispensable
seuls les langues des plongeurs percer
l'obscurité
et dans ce dédale seule la ligne de vie
verte indique le chemin du retour
[Musique]
rapidement on a il ya un dépôt comme si
la briquette rouge qui recouvre
l'ensemble de la salle la briquette se
décompose ça fait une petite couche
petite pellicule au fond et des convois
commencé à brasser ça fait des images
comme l'océan à 90 une image reste un
match entier de se retrouver dans
l'autre est trouble comme il n'ya pas de
surfaces libres on est vraiment sous
plafond le lot va jusqu'au plafond ben
il faut il faut avoir confiance en son
matériel c'est pour ça qu'on met une
main courante un fil d'ariane dans tous
les projets au spéléo c'est la même
chose
chaque année quinze personnes doivent
leur salut à ses plongeurs surentraînés
après une demi-heure de plonger les
hommes retrouvent l'air libre
en juillet 2010 c'est cette technique
d'exploration aquatique qu'on utilisait
les plongeurs ce jour-là ce quart
autrichien vient de tomber dans la seine
garé à côté du pont d'iéna le chauffeur
a oublié de serrer le frein
à l'arrivée des pompiers le car est
entièrement sous l'eau
dans un premier temps les plongeurs
doivent s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas de
victime
heureusement très vite il réalise que le
bus est vide
en fait les 51 passagers et les deux
chauffeurs assiste à un spectacle dans
un cabaret
[Musique]
deuxième étape sortir le quart de l'eau
il faudra deux jours
et la mobilisation de quinze plongeurs
l'impression de voir une photo
[Musique]
24 heures sur 24
trois pompiers state veille à la
préservation de ce patrimoine
inestimable car aucun musée même les
mieux gardés ouais c'est damien tu peut
m'ouvrir l'a30 la pnv 30 04 mersen est à
l'abri d'un incendie la 30 04
merci bien allez bon courage
donc ici on se trouve sur la terrasse et
pour la petite anecdote c'est ici en
2013 donc il ya eu un incendie dans le
musée
un matin d'avril 2013 une épaisse fumée
noire s'élève au-dessus du musée faisant
craindre le pire pour les oeuvres et les
visiteurs les systèmes de sécurité ont
dirigé les fumées vers l'extérieur et en
peu de temps les pompiers ont maîtrisé
l'incendié
l'intervention a été assez spectaculaire
de l'extérieur voyais à un panache c'est
violent de l'extérieur mais aucun
tableau qu'une oeuvre n'a été touché
le public a été évacué sans encombre
aucun blessé pendant l'évacuation
dans les heures qui suivent la cause de
l'incendié est vite identifié
c'est dans les espaces techniques cachée
du public que l' incendie s'est déclaré
l'agente est venu intervenir là dessus
afin dé coupe il ya des étincelles qui
sont partis ont enflammé toute cette
doublure là s'est passé à travers les
grilles dans le tuer dans le conduit
jusqu'à l'extérieur il est 9h30 le musée
ouvre ses portes la gare se remplit
d'une partie de ses trois millions de
visiteurs annuels cent soixante huit
mille objets tableaux et sculptures
s'offre à leurs yeux
ils ignorent qu au sous-sol dans les
réserves on envisage le pire
l'obligation de devoir évacuer les
oeuvres
but de cet exercice c'est tout d'abord
je rationaliser le décrochage d'un épi
chance parce que c'est la nuit aux
horaires de fermeture du musée il n'y a
personne que vous puissiez dans des
conditions correctes de conservation
préventive manipuler et stockés
provisoirement les oeuvres dans ses
rayonnages des trésors à manipuler avec
précaution
damien redevient un simple élèves
le but va être dans un premier temps de
vider cet épilogue donc vous
spontanément vous procédurier comment
mais moi je partirai du bas puis vers le
haut pour éviter de faire tomber sur
sont exactement absolument donc on va y
aller avant toute chose principe rien
qui dépasse pour des bords de match et
les oeuvres à les attentions pour les
lever
on regarde en haut on gagne pas contre
notre cadre ok tu tournes et c'est toi
qui vas aller voter
et monte alors vous pouvoir des masses
en premier
troisième personne peut le récupérer là
on est conscient que ce qu'on déplace
vaut très cher faut perdre sa pension la
laci je le fais tomber si je sais un peu
comme quand on déplace une victime quoi
on à l'appréhension dit
faut pas que je la fasse tomber quoi
c'est
déjà une jambe cassée s'il l'a fait
tomber je grave sont caduques à celle de
jean macé c'est qu'on n'a pas fait on
n'a pas bien fait notre travail donc là
c'est pareil on a la prétention y voit
attention c'est précieux c'est
irremplaçable
les tableaux anciens sont extrêmement
fragiles
savoir les manier n'est pas si simple
la crue de la seine de juin 2015 a
révélé la vulnérabilité de ces réserves
elles sont situées sous le niveau du
fleuve
typique de ce qu'on a eu donc ça c'est
des microfissures en fait il y avait de
l'eau qu'ils remontaient par capillarité
et au niveau notamment de certaines
portes on s'est rendu compte que la
résine qui a été appliquée au sol dans
les années 80 étaient craquelés mais
c'était vraiment des micros craquelures
et en fait quand on appuie dessus ou
vice et est gorgé d'eau et quand on
enlevait le pied ça faisait comme des
pitbulls saviez gloup gloup donc on
voyait bien qu'on avait une pression
énorme et qui on s'attendait à un moment
ou un autre qui est un geyser qui qui
sortent donc on a décidé en effet en
urgence avec l'accord des ministères
d'évacuer l'intégralité
chaque année une crue équivalente à
celle de 1901 est annoncé mais les
trésors du musée d'orsay sont entre de
bonnes mains
caserne de ménilmontant il est 14 heures
40 on retrouve and is comme tous les
médecins de la brigade elle alterne
entre la régulation au téléphone et les
interventions sur le terrain ou par sur
une douleur thoracique chez 20 patients
l'infarctus
les ambulance de réanimation celle avec
un médecin sont environ une dizaine sur
paris et la petite couronne
le secteur couvert par anisé vaste
l'intervention est à 8 km et il faut un
quart d'heure pour arriver sur les lieux
le médecin n'a que peu d'informations en
arrivant c'est toujours un peu la
surprise
face à elle un quinquagénaire qui porte
des traces de coups et l'agresseur n'est
pas n'importe qui sa frappe et de la
loire fraco
suite
mais qu'il arrive chez les gens on
rentre dans leur intérieur dans une
situation d'urgence parce que il ya
quelqu'un qui est malade ou en détresse
est donc en fait rien n'est caché on est
confronté directement à la misère ou à
la violence familiale d'accord ok vous
étiez vous graphique on allait voir
alice craint que l'homme soit victime
non pas des coups portés par son fils
mais du stress provoqué par l'agression
la couleur de l'année dernière quand
vous avez fait l'infarctus c'est la même
c'est pour ça que vous avez à fait le
droit j'ai tout ce côté là qu'il fait
mal j'ai les dangers comme si jamais
vous paraît comme l'année dernière vu
des crimes douleur vraiment typique je
prends 140 sérieux en plus il a eu un
gros coup de stress avec l'altercation
avec son fils et on sait très bien qu'un
coup de stress peut entraîner un
problème cardiaque pour dissiper ces
doutes
le médecin a besoin de connaître l'état
du coeur du patient
l'équipe lui fait alors un bilan complet
elle vérifie son rythme cardiaque et son
taux d'oxygène dans le sang
tout semble normal mais pour en avoir le
coeur net admise contacter le
cardiologue du malade pour une douleur
thoracique décrit comme identique à
celle j'apprends que le patient est de
nature très angoissé il a fait un petit
infarctus il a pas de séquelles et il a
extrêmement bien récupérer donc le
cardiologue midi ne vous inquiétez pas
au point de vue cardiaque pour l'instant
tout va bien tout est rassurant mais il
faut quand même aller à l'hôpital aux
urgences pour faire des prises de sang
et vérifier qui a que ça bouge pas
on n'avait versé que quelques heures et
une fois que les prises de sang seront
bonnes si elles sont bonnes ce que je
pense qu'il va se passer vous pourrez
rentrer à la maison il n'y a pas
d'urgence vitale mais le patient
nécessite tout de même un passage à
l'hôpital ce sont les premiers secours
qui vont les conduire and is elle doit
redevenir disponibles pour d'autres
urgences
voir le but du jeu c'est pas de rester
sur intervention trop longtemps il n'y a
pas tant d'ambulances de réanimation que
ça sur paris donc il faut faire les
gestes
qui permettent à la personne de
récupérer mais il faut aussi si c'est
pas nécessaire d'amener les patients à
l'hôpital il faut savoir les confier aux
premiers secours pour être disponible si
jamais il ya quelqu'un qui fait un arrêt
cardiaque ou un infarctus dans quelques
jours une autre épreuve attend église
elle va devoir descendre en rappel du
haut de la tour montparnasse
retour à la caserne de clichy sous bois
dans les sous sols les pompiers pouce de
la fonte
à la brigade le sport c'est quatre
heures par jour
dernière arrivée dans la caserne gabin
sait qu'il doit redoubler d'efforts
physiques manger le minimum demandait
pour être en compagnie quand on arrive
en tant que première classe on n'a pas
le niveau physique de certains caporaux
caporaux-chefs ou même certains sous
officier donc c'est pour ça on doit
s'entraîner
en sport pour atteindre un niveau
supérieur
mais l'entraînement à peine finie une
sonnerie bien particulière retentit
c'est celle qui annonce le départ pour
feu
un incendie vient de se déclencher
quelque part sur le secteur il faut
s'équiper au plus vite en feu ça m'a
toujours attirée et le combattre
c'est un des plus grands rêves quoi il
attend longo où je ferai une grosse
intervention ce jour est il arrivé pour
l'heure impossible de le savoir
le combat contre le feu et avant tout
une course de vitesse en quelques
minutes l'équipe de gamins arrivent sur
intervention
et ce n'est pas vraiment ce à quoi on
s'attendait
oui on fait aussi des feux de poubelles
ça m'intéresse un petit peu moins mais
bon ça fait partie du métier
gâtés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
il ne faut que deux coups de jets d'eau
pour éteindre les flammes
les feux c'est pas que des grands
moments là c'est déjà quasiment été à
notre arrivée on serait parti du jeu ont
fait pas tout tous les jours des [ __ ]
fait heureusement pour la population
retour au milieu de la nuit
après une longue journée de tâches
d'intérêt général d'entraînement
physique et d'intervention gabin peut
enfin se reposer
[Musique]
et alors que la nuit est bien entamée à
clichy sous bois
quelques kilomètres plus au sud
c'est à 20 mètres sous terre que des
pompiers s'apprêtent à s'entraîner cette
nuit leur terrain de jeu les catacombes
de paris
voilà près de paris a été construite sur
des carrières les surfaces souterraine
occupe près d'un tiers de la ville est
déjà l'accès est à peine plus large que
les épaules l'appréhension
pour la plupart c'est une première
cliquez complètement déstabilisant mais
c'est bien pour ça qu'on vient ici parce
que c'est particulier c'est confiné ça
ressemble à plat de l'intervention en
sites souterrains
les gauches attention avant de débuter
l'exercice pour les mettre en condition
julien impose aux pompiers une marche
forcée d'une heure voit les pousser à
peu au cul
quand on ya peu
on est dans les sous sols de paris qui
était un véritable gruyère on est sous
terre l'ambiance est très humide il faut
il ya des ossements donc supérieure des
crânes du fémur on sait qu'il ya des
gens qui se promènent dedans on peut
tomber nez à nez avec lui donc c'est
vrai que des fois on a on peut faire
certaines rencontres qui font peur c'est
toujours une ambiance particulière c'est
vraiment un endroit mythique de paris
arrivé sur zone julien accorde une pause
et s'improvise guide touristique
c'était une salle de repos pour les mecs
qui en même temps imposer des petites
pierres ça servait à analyser à exposer
toutes différentes pierres qu'il pouvait
trouver dans les caraïbes
il se doit est-ce que vous m'écoutez ah
ouais
l'exercice semble simple il suffit de
porter un homme jusqu'à la sortie
c'est renouf à son insu sarah juillet
que la team le torse nu mais voilà
il est 23h à laisser passer partie des
23 une seule règle avancer coûte que
coûte
si on regrette ce rythme là
[Musique]
le brancardage commence il va durer des
heures et s'annonce très difficile
au même moment dans la banlieue sud de
paris une ambulance par au secours d'un
homme jeune c'est un homme de 35 ans qui
étiez petite tenue
qui sera le colisée est faite de crise
l'homme peut être en danger l'épilepsie
provoque de violentes contractions
musculaires il a été retrouvé au bord
d'une route au sud de paris il faut dix
minutes à l'équipe pour se rendre sur
place on arrive assez rapidement on se
rend compte que la victime a déjà été
mis par les premiers intervenants dans
le camion des pompiers ce qui est une
situation assez favorable pour nous
c'est un environnement qui est propre
dans lequel il n'y a pas beaucoup de
place c'est vrai mais c'est bien pensé
monsieur monsieur monsieur
je suis le médecin des pompiers d'accord
qu'est-ce que vous prenez comme
médicament pour l'épilepsie on sait pas
vous ne savez pas vous être agressés
monsieur vous rappelez
d'accord
que s'est il réellement passé l'homme
sont le gaz lacrymogènes mais il ne
porte aucune trace de coups
tout à coup il est victime d'une
nouvelle crise ces spasmes sont si
violents que les pompiers ont du mal à
le maintenir remettez la spi ça va être
c'est vachement bizarre comme saison
[Musique]
au moment du pic de la crise il est
extrêmement agitée hélas le patient
présente des mouvements extrêmement
bruyant se demande si c'est qu'ils en
rajoutent pas impossible et pas du
théâtre
clément soupçonne la victime de simuler
c'est de résister à la crise
tout le problème de l'intervention c'est
de savoir si ce patient est en train de
se moquer de nous ou bien une maladie
psychiatrique qui fait qu'il doit qu'il
fait des manifestations un petit peu
hystérique ou bien s'il a une crise
d'épilepsie réel
mais vous êtes en
écoute et moi avec les pompiers vous
avez fait une crise d'épilepsie
c'est les pompiers en accord
pour calmer ces crises clément décide de
lui poser une perfusion
reste également on vous pose d'une
perfusion pour l'épilepsie
est allé l'homme retrouve peu à peu son
calme il aura fallu une heure à clément
pour venir à bout de ces crises
se nomme on a pris en charge et détresse
vitale il fait plus crise d'épilepsie
donc ils en sécurité maintenant j'ai pas
d'origine certaines à son épilepsie est
ce que c'est juste parce qu'il
épileptiques est-ce qu'ils épient les
petits qui est alcoolique ou est-ce
qu'en plus il a pris des coups dans la
tête ça va ça va clément ne connaîtra
jamais la vérité l'homme va être
hospitalisé la mission s'arrête là pour
le médecin et pour son équipe
retour sous terre
dans les catacombes les pompiers portent
leur bronquard de 90 kilos depuis
bientôt deux heures
[Musique]
alors d'où vient ce voyage et
voilà
le fait d'être sous terre dans les
carrières
là c'est gigantesque quoi on a le vent
froid qui nous arrive dessus on voit à
peine les voitures en bas et on se dit
il va falloir que je descendais que je
me jette dans le vide c'est difficile
l'exercice commence
[Musique]
clément se lance sans aucune
appréhension
je suis
[Musique]
en à peine vingt secondes de rappel
il se pose sur la terrasse en
contrepartie
[Musique]
sous les yeux danese
cramponné à la rambarde bonjour d'un
grain un mannequin aux technologies doté
de la parole sert de victimes est ce qui
s'est passé les messieurs dites moi
vous avez mal ou du toit où vous avez
mal monsieur
les mélanges d'accord écoutez monsieur
je vous connais vous me dîtes si je vous
fait mal là vous ce mal ou pas au niveau
du cou
ce mannequin qui représente une victime
qui peut respirer ou ne pas respirer qui
peut parler on peut pas refuser qui fait
le poids de près d'un homme la même
corpulence et les instructeurs étaient
cachés derrière une petite baie vitrée à
l'intérieur de la tour montparnasse est
téléguidée ce mannequin à l'extérieur
pour nous permettre vraiment de rentrer
dans ce scénario de rentrer dans le jeu
allez monsieur tout va bien le réalisme
est tel que l'état de santé du mannequin
commence à se dégrader écoute je te
rappelle pour tenir quelques constantes
il a une tension à neuf et demi sur
quatre tons branche à un système de
monitorage on peut récupérer le signal
électrique d'un fokker qu'il n'a pas on
peut l'ausculter écouter des poumons
virtuel on peut le persuader on peut
faire de perfuser dans le dos la victime
est médicalisé est stabilisé par clément
puis elle est confiée aux hommes du
grain
la montée se termine pour clément c'est
bientôt aux autres pompiers de se
confronter au vide
anne-lise va-t-il oser se lancer
honnêtement dans ma tête je me disais il
faut que tu fasses mais j'étais quand
même pas sûr de franchir le cap
le moment crucial est arrivé
le moment où on doit se mettre à
califourchon sur la rambarde il ya une
sensation de données en fait
oui après comme ça d'accord
soustelle plus de 200 mètres de vide
la mise au vide c'est quelque chose de
difficile j'étais bloqué j'avais
l'impression que j'avais tous mes
muscles tétanisés
donc j'y vais là
tu maîtrises
ouais ok
anli s'élance sous les regards
admiratifs de ses collègues
mais elle sait qu'une fois arrivé en bas
il faudra remonter
vraiment courageuse à ses shows way pour
moi c'est chaud
on va il ya des collègues qui nous
attendent donc il ya un côté qui
finalement est rassurant ça s'est plutôt
bien passé par contre la montée c'est
beaucoup plus physique parce qu'il faut
remonter à la force de la jambe et du
bras avec la poignée une corde autour du
pied pour pousser une poignée pour tirer
analyse doit se hisser sur 20 m moi j'ai
eu plus de mal à la montée qu'à la
descente à
l'effort est intense et à 200 mètres
dans le vide impossible de se détendre
en fait on monte on tourne autour de la
corde et
il ya des moments en fait on est face au
vide et on nous dit vas-y continue à
monter mais il n'y a pas de paroisse ya
rien et ce moment là a été le moment le
plus dur je cours
j'ai
encore quelques mètres pour mettre fin
au calvaire
super
anne-lise les franchi sous le regard de
clément
je remonte ton corps mais à nice n'est
pas au bout de ses frayeurs
darmenté management
sa sortie
ah bon
anne-lise ne s'en pensais pas capable
mais elle a vaincu la toujours et sa
peur du vide pour moi c'est non
pour d'autres c'est rien du tout ils
font ils ont l'habitude mon niveau c'est
un challenge que j'ai réussi à
pour les pompiers les lieux
emblématiques de la capitale ne sont pas
que des lieux d'exercice
direction à présent l'un des endroits
les plus luxueux de paris mars 2012 un
incendie se déclare au coeur de la
capitale la mythique place vendôme haut
lieu de la joaillerie et loyers sous un
nuage de fumée noire est toxique au
deuxième sous-sol du parking 52 voitures
brûlent parmi elles beaucoup de voitures
de luxe 400 personnes des immeubles
alentour sont évacués
[Musique]
et ce en décidant d'aller en france une
centaine de pompiers tentent de
reprendre le contrôle des cinq étages du
parking mais intervenir dans un parking
souterrain c'est très compliqué
la difficulté est tout simplement
d'approcher le sinistre
les accès au sous sol sont limitées il
est impossible de contourner le foyer et
les soldats du feu sont bloqués par les
épaisses fumées toxiques
paul
il faudra cinq heures aux pompiers pour
venir à bout du sinistre
un seul blessé léger est à déplorer mais
les dégâts auraient pu être bien plus
grave
cette longue lutte a poussé la brigade à
innover pour faire évoluer les
techniques de combat contre le feu
paris xvème arrondissement
ce samedi matin les hommes de la caserne
du blanc-mesnil celle de sébastien vont
s'entraîner en sous-sol et c'est un
exercice très spécial qui s'annonce en
effet face aux défis des incendies en
milieu souterrain les pompiers de paris
met en place des parades à 30 mètres
sous le trottoir les pompiers simule
l'extinction d'un incendie non pas avec
de l'eau mais avec de la mousse on va
faire les stocks sont mus d'un première
mission c'est blanc minute qui va la
faire donc une fois qu'on a rempli de
mousse ça va vérifier restrictions je
veux des comptes rendus réguliers quand
vous arrivez en bas
et quand vous sortez là bas seuls deux
casernes dont celle de sébastien
maîtrise technique le feu pour pouvoir
évoluer
et prendre de l'ampleur il a besoin
d'oxygène namouh salle elle va venir
prendre la place de l'oxygène donc c'est
on va éteindre le feu par étouffement
tout simplement attention la mousson ben
rien donc il faut absolument avoir un
lien évident entre les celle là elle est
celle là bas absolument
l'habitude de travailler dans les fumées
là les fumées sont remplacés par de la
mousse donc
c'est juste une soirée mousse à samedi
soir surclassé samedi matin
les pompiers finissent de s'équiper deux
priorités pouvoir respirer normalement
et communiquer avec les autres
un haéri notre appareil respiratoire
isolant avec notre masque corps est
ensuite que
notre caméra thermique pour détecter
tous les points chauds
guide
vide un autre port hall qui permet de
rester en liaison avec un mobile home
les pompiers ne travaille jamais seule
question de sécurité
une fois prêt c'est le moment de
s'immerger dans la mousse
allez on est nombreux à aller centre est
arrivé en bas c'est un gigantesque bas
mot 100 qui attend sébastien
il est rejoint quelques instants plus
tard par son équipier
le soleil commence à se coucher sur les
quais de seine à la caserne de la
monnaie une équipe de plongeurs selon
sur les eaux du fleuve ce sont des
hommes grenouilles équipés de bouteilles
l'équipe samara une pile de pont le but
de l'exercice
explorer les fonds à bien la navigation
à vérification est scellé pompière
d'exercice se plonger on croyait la rive
droite pour royal arrête europe les gars
vont rester dans l'arche ok je rappeler
une communication contrat sera deux
courts gauche trois corps à droite à
coup vous êtes en sécurité
et voilà encore sur une plongée d'une
demi heure profitez-en pour faire
reconnaître la pelouse de cons les quais
et profiter du courant prendre de bonnes
sensations
lorsque les personnes tombées à l'eau
ont coulé ce sont ces plongeurs qui sont
chargés d'aller les chercher
des fois au fond de l'eau dont il ya
très très peu de visibilité et du coup
on peut
ne plus savoir où exactement où on est
comme moi j'ai des moyens de
communication peut leur dire soit gauche
soit à droite et pour leur dire quand
est ce qu'ils sont en sécurité
les hommes se laisse descendre au fond
de l'eau la seine dans paris peut être
profonde jusqu'à 6 mètres dans le fond
on retrouve ce que les parisiens ont
jeté tout ce qui tombe des bateaux et
balade inédite au fond de la scène
y en a qui sont plus ou moins surpris
par ce qu'on peut trouver dans la seine
trouvé des poissons des gros silure
petites anguilles des petits poissons
sebala en équipe
[Musique]
il ya de tout c'est un bazar sans nom on
trouve des bouteilles d'eau des balles
on trouve des télés on trouve vraiment
de tout tout ce qui peut y avoir dans un
appartement on peut le trouver dans la
salle
la nuit vient de tomber c'est le moment
de remonter
une demi heure
une demi heure sur la 3° je pense qu'ils
vont à de bien réfléchir pour être
content de sortir des points d'eau
chaude
la nuit est tombée sur la ville lumière
mais la semaine n'est pas encore
terminée pour les pompiers
dimanche matin à l'est de paris
attention ça va glisser un peu à l'heure
où blanchit la campagne
deux hommes se glisse dans un bois ce
que ça peut lui faire une zone dessus
aussi acier bien c'est à l'avancé un peu
hagarde la voilà j'ai un chemin là j'ai
eu un mur du cimetière
je vois des seuls à pouvoir bien repéré
pour être sûr du coup comme m ces
pompiers cherche à brouiller les pistes
ils cherchent un endroit isolé
[Musique]
au téléphone c'est bon tu admires
vibreur par contre et c'est de mettre au
mieux de bien de planquer et puis voilà
tellement de soucis tu as honte à
pailherols vraiment yaakov de toi tu
hésites pas j'ai caché le collègue on a
levé qu'il opère à servette qui va
arriver et en fait on va simuler une
vraie intervention c'est à dire qu'on va
simuler une personne égarée ça peut être
par exemple une personne âgée qui
eyeliner qui part se promener bas dans
une forêt et malheureusement qui revient
pas dans la famille s'inquiète une
personne aussi tentative de suicide
malheureusement des gens qui veulent se
suicider bas partent aussi dans les
forêts pour s'isoler et mettre fin à
leur jour où un enfant qui est parti en
promenade qui s'est égaré qui s'égarent
et qui a fait une chute pareille voilà
donc c'est des sièges encore en train
clairement la victime est caché
camouflé dans les fourrés comme si elle
était perdue
voilà comme ça impeccable
jennifer pompier maître chien dirige
l'équipe de recherche car lorsque des
personnes sont introuvables les pompiers
de paris se fie au long de leurs
instruments les plus infaillibles
l'odorat de leur chien
mais avant de les lancer
jennifer prend quelques renseignements
celle ci prend des médicaments pour se
sucrer
je sais pas je sais pas
sa couleur de cheveux il est bras
sa taille à peu près 1 m 75
il a vu partir là en fait là il a vu
partir le petit mur en béton et après
ce jour là il fait froid ça va nous
aider dans la recherche avec les chiens
parce que les odeurs sont plus volatiles
reste plus facilement au sol au lieu de
partir ce qui fait que notre chien aura
beaucoup plus de facilité à retrouver
cette odeur qui va rester à sa hauteur
plutôt que quand il fait chaud les
odeurs ont tendance à monter et à partir
beaucoup plus vite
la truffe en l'air l'efs le chien de la
brigade s'activent la zone de recherches
est immense un bois de plusieurs
hectares
seule solution diviser le secteur en
quarts et de 200 mètres de long sur 200
m de large l'équivalent de près de six
terrains de foot
le chien doit les ratisser un an il va
partout
dirigée par son maître qui le
réorientant sifflant
[Musique]
il va capturer toutes les odeurs et des
qui va prendre une odeur il va se
rapprocher au maximum de victimes
d'après moi avec mon déplacement je vais
partir à gauche je l'appelais il va me
suivre il va le dépasser dès qu'il aura
dépassé hop je repars de l'autre côté
je le rappelle il reçu et heureux des
passes et en faisant ça en fait je vais
quadrillé le secteur que j'ai à fouiller
la quête peut durer plusieurs heures
mais heureusement pour la victime
aujourd'hui ce sera beaucoup plus rapide
s'il ya quelqu'un et que le mettra bien
sectorisé son secteur le chien tombera
dessus c'est infaillible le chien à
partir du moment où il aura pris son
odeur il erra sur sa victime
c'est vous
[Musique]
après avoir trouvé la fausse victime là
c'est la récompense des moments de jeu
après exercice est très important pour
le chien ça permet de le renforcer dans
le travail qui vient d'effectuer et ça
leur récompense ça
c'est la finalité de ce qu'on lui
demande de rechercher la victime pour
jouer donc en gros le jour où il n'y a
pas de jouer il va rechercher la victime
et lui ce qui va tendre s'est joué le
jeu
chaque année une cinquantaine de
personnes sont retrouvées par les chiens
de la brigade dans les forêts et dans
les parcs d'île de france
dernière matinée à la caserne de clichy
sous bois
le jeune gabin abandonne son uniforme
[Musique]
autour la ville
il est en permission pour plusieurs
jours il va retourner en bretagne même
si son métier sa passion ne le quitte
jamais vraiment
[Musique]
le fier d'appartenir à ce corps d'arles
de l'armée j'ai même du mal des fois à
me dire je suis pompier de paris mais
j'y suis quoi
en cette fin de semaine damien le
pompier du musée d'orsay vous continue
ses rondes
elle le même parfois vers un panorama
unique
vers une des plus belles vues
de la plus belle ville du monde
[Musique]
et lorsque les pompiers peuvent prendre
le temps de l'admirer et qu'ils doivent
désigner leurs quartiers préférés
naturellement c'est à leur caserne
qu'ils pensent à un petit pincement au
coeur pour mon secteur
mon ancien secteur jusque là bas avec
notre dame j'avais déjà fait plusieurs
points ou dans paris mais ça là
on a la défense
montmartre
qu'est-ce qu'on va retrouver notre dame
pourra retrouver la tour montparnasse on
va trouver
la tour eiffel les plus grands monuments
de paris
je me verrais bien posé ma petite table
et puis faire un petit dîner
une pause bien méritée pour ses 8500
hommes et femmes de la brigade des
pompiers de paris qui nous protège
depuis 50 ans
[Musique]